hey youtubers is Charlie DC we continued
so new episode of arrow anarchy is back
and we found out one more person that's
definitely not in that grave at the end
of the season so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway that's going on
right now all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so let's just
start with top 5 WTF and that I'll do
some Easter eggs starting with number 5
the opening montage Oliver in the
emergency room with the doctors and
Felicity right after the accident
cutting back and forth in montage
between him interrogating ghost and then
killing one apparently no kill rule off
the table now if you remember all the
way back to season 2 he broke his know
kill rule when count vertigo almost
injected Felicity with vertigo the
original account for it ago not the one
from season 3 so he's totally willing to
break that no kill rule for Felicity and
he started lying to his friends again
but more on that in a second but I just
like the way they edited the intro the
way it's meant to put you into Oliver
his mind like it's completely confused
all jumbled up it's just a blur of blood
and punching and kicking and craziness
very disorienting very effective on to
my number 4 WTF Oliver has decided to
kill damian darhk-- and he doesn't care
what it takes
he straight-up asks Quentin to burn his
bridge he says there's a place in the
arrow cave that you can live in we have
a place where you can hide out because
you won't be able to go to your house
after this go and of course being the
good friend is happy to give up that
information anything to take this son of
a down but it leads them to
anarchy
welcome back Lonnie Machin haven't seen
you in a while looks like you got some
extra city miles on you there in case
you missed it that a was actually
painted in his stepparents blood so the
episode is all about revenge and they
had this really nice symmetry between
every characters arc where everybody is
out for some form of revenge Oliver
wants revenge against damian darhk--
anarchy wants revenge against damian
darhk-- even in the flashbacks Conklin
wants revenge against Oliver that that's
why he whipped him because Oliver got
Conklin whipped at the beginning of the
season so he have all these characters
that are out for revenge but in each of
their arts within each of their arcs
there's a person like a friend or a
confidante that acts as the voice of
reason even the campaign manager tries
to be Thea's voice of reason mostly
because he wants to bone her but will
give him a pass so no one wants their
friends you know whoever whoever they
are that's out for revenge
lose their humanity Diggle had that line
where he's like Oliver I don't want you
to lose the humanity that you've
regained it's the same thing in Thea's
situation if she were to kill anarchy
she'd go right back to being a monster
which is interesting because damian
darhk-- did not kill Oliver so that's
almost like saying he is not a monster
albeit for the end tag sequence where
it's like you know what you have to do
you have to kill that son of a but
on to my number three WTF sliding back a
little bit Oliver freeze anarchy and
asks him tells him really tells him to
make sure that damian darhk-- is dead
really awesome hardcore scene but I'd
love when it just falls apart in the air
okay and all of us like I don't know
what to do
this was the only plan I had and then I
thought of the trailer moment with John
Barrowman character turist Oliver and
says you know the thing I love about you
Oliver is you look awesome but you were
just the dumbest thing on this planet
Oliver Queen explained very effective
when he knows what he wants to do but
not so great at the long game to go
beats the out of his brother to get
information Thea wounds Anarchy a little
bit like sticks the arrow in him
everyone back slides a little bit during
the episode before they ultimately
reached the right conclusion on a my
number two WTF though team arrow saves
damien darhk's family from anarchy you
know we don't really know what this
family relationship is like what it
works how she is part of hive but we do
know that he calls them his family so
I'm assuming this is his wife and this
is his daughter is actually a pretty
good fight scene they had some good
fight scenes in the episode arrow does
fight scenes better than most shows on
television just incredibly kinetic very
good choreography good cinematography
fight scenes totally on point but on to
my number one WTF so this is kind of a
tie between Felicity never being able to
walk again that is just a prognosis we
could talk about how that's not gonna
stick all night but damian darhk-- also
lets oliver spend a couple of weeks as
he says with his family after which it
is back on do you just love that
mirrored scene at the very end where
damien darhk's wife is like you should
have killed that son of a and
felicity is also like you know what you
have to do now you have to kill that son
of a it's almost like this woman
is damien darhk's version of felicity
but she's not evil felicity there's so
many other comic-book characters that
would be better for that just address
that real quick damien darhk's wife here
has a bit of a subplot
i don't know how big she is in hive but
she's gonna be running against all of
her for
the mayorship of starch city Felicity on
the other side of that we have to talk
about this a little bit the writers have
already confirmed she is not gonna
become Oracle it was a big deal about
this a couple weeks ago I made a couple
videos about it
there was this footage that was released
where it was like she's never gonna walk
again and I'm like that doesn't sound
right maybe may you know maybe they want
her to be Oracle it felt very misleading
and then the writers did officially come
out and say no she you know we're not
doing the Oracle thing we're gonna do
something a little bit different they
didn't say what they were doing
obviously they're not they're not gonna
spoil it only to say that they're not
gonna make her the Barbara Gordon Oracle
character what I do think is gonna
happen is if she will be without the use
of her leg so she'll be in a wheelchair
or she'll be sitting down in all of her
scenes for at least the next four or
five episodes and then when her father
comes or towards the end of the season
she'll find a way to get up to make
herself whole now obviously I think a
lot has to happen before that can go
down and I'm wondering you know just
because one of the characters was like
you got some steel on you if they're
gonna use some tech to help fix felicity
if it's gonna be like this arrow flash
collaboration mr. terrific
Caitlin Cisco all the scientists at STAR
Labs Ray Palmer they could probably find
a way to make Felicity walk again with
some techno organics but but we'll have
to see I think this is just gonna be
Felicity's island her crucible to
survive for the rest of the season in
addition to actual villains like
physical villains but when Oliver rolled
up into the hospital didn't you just
wonder when her mother was like we're on
the second doctor they brought someone
in from Central City and you're like
wait is that Henry Allen Henry Allen's a
doctor he actually looked at Barry scans
when Barry broke his spine maybe he's a
spinal surgeon but obviously John Wesley
Shipp isn't on the show but I think it'd
be an awesome way to have him cameo on
arrow but I do think it would be fun if
mr. terrific helped her out with her
physical therapy and while they were
doing physical therapy they thought up
like really creative solutions for the
company like here's some new tech or
here might ease fears or here's a way to
fix you so we'll see for better for
worse and as a lot of you saw like I was
seeing people talking about it on
Twitter yes Oliver and Felicity were not
wearing their engagement rings in the
limo at the end so I definitely think
that something happens with damian
darhk-- to torpedo their marriage in my
heart I also feel like superheroes
aren't allowed to have happy marriages
it's just like the Batman Bruce Wayne
thing they're just
so torn up inside that the engine that
drives them to be a superhero also
destroys most of their personal
relationships and that doesn't mean they
can't have positive relationships they
can totally have friends with benefits
but as long as there's someone out there
to be God just like Felicity says what's
damian darhk-- doing in bali it's it's
all about that idea of like if there's
still people that needs saving then you
don't have time to do the family thing
so make of that what you will
most of the main cast is signed through
season 7 so I think that they'll all be
back but Diggle just shot to the top of
my list about who's in that grave
think about who would make felicity that
upset she's not super close with Quentin
maybe it's her mother
maybe it's Thea I don't want it to be
Thea because they've already killed Thea
and then brought her back so I do think
it's someone else that that's why Diggle
us at the top of my list but let me know
in the comments after this episode who
do you think is in that grave and if you
guys didn't see it there's been a whole
bunch of DC stuff happening this week
they call it DC Week for a reason
legends of tomorrow starts tomorrow it
is gonna be crazy
I think it's only an hour long but I'll
totally post my video after it airs and
then there are a couple other videos I'm
catching up on I am gonna do an Asian
carter video that I'll probably post
sometime on Thursday if you guys haven't
seen it yet I just posted my flash video
from last night you can click here to
watch that as flash episode 10 and you
can click here for the Suicide Squad and
Wonder Woman trailers thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight